翻訳: Toshihiro Suzuki
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
私は今
夫婦でケーキ屋を営んでいます
売り場と厨房の他に
３人掛けのカウンター席があるだけの
小さなお店です
そこには おしゃべりをしに
コーヒーを飲みに来る人や
通勤や買い物の途中で寄る人
そして
食事制限で
おやつを我慢しなければならない人
その人の家族や友人が訪れます
ちょっと普通のケーキ屋さんと違いますよね
私たちのお店のケーキは
血糖値が上がりにくい材料を使った
低糖質なケーキなのです
低糖質と言っても
見た目も甘さも
ほとんど普通のケーキと変わりません
糖質が抑えられているんです
でも そこが大事なんです
今日は
私がお店を始めることになった理由と
お店を始めてから起こった出来事を
皆さんにお話ししたいと思います
皆さんは
突然
自分が大好きなお菓子を
食べてはいません
と言われたら どうしますか？
我慢できますか？
それとも
こっそり食べてしまいますか？
今から10年前
私は 経験したことのない
体調の異変に襲われました
喉が異様に渇き
何をやってもだるくて疲れる
すぐに病院に行ったところ
１型糖尿病と診断されました
栄養士という仕事柄 知識はあったものの
まさか自分が糖尿病になるなんて
考えたこともなくて
最初はピンときませんでした
しかし
悩んでいる暇もなく
インスリンの注射と
カロリー制限の課せられた食事の日々が
始まりました
糖尿病には１型と２型 二種類あります
遺伝や生活習慣が原因の
２型糖尿病とは違い
１型は突然発症するのが特徴です
赤ちゃんの頃に発症する人もいれば
私のように
大人になってから発症することもあります
２型糖尿病は
運動や食事で
改善もできるのですが
１型糖尿病は
インスリンという血糖値を下げるホルモンが
身体の中で作られなくなってしまうので
代わりに 腕や太もも お腹などに
インスリンの注射を打つことになります
現在のところ
根本的な治療方法はありません
ダイエットで
自ら食事制限しているのとは違い
食べられないストレスというのは
想像以上でした
なぜ私が糖尿病になってしまったのか
人と比べ落ち込んだり
つい余計に食べてしまった時には
悪いことをしてしまったという後悔
将来 合併症になるのではないか
という不安を抱え
未来が怖く
目先が真っ暗になりました
今まで普通に食べていた
たった１つのケーキでさえ
食べたことを後悔するものとなりました
私は元々 食べることが好きで
友人や家族と
コーヒーを片手におやつを食べながら
会話を楽しむ時間が大好きでしたが
糖尿病が 私から
大好きな「おやつの時間」を奪ったのです
そして
病気から目を背け
日々の血糖値を測るのをやめ
一人で隠れて食べるようになりました
悪くなっているであろう血糖値を知るのが怖く
病院へ行くのが憂鬱でつらい日々でした
ある時
どうしても病気のことを忘れたくて
いっそ
私のことを誰も知らない世界に行こうと思い
インドに一人旅に行くことにしました
なんとなくインドって
変われそうな気がしませんか
（笑）
でも実際は変われません
海外で２ヶ月近く現実逃避しても心は晴れず
頭の中は常に
糖尿病のこと
食べ物のことでいっぱいでした
結局私は逃げているだけで
向き合わなければ何も変わっていませんでした
その後
帰ってきてから
私は 砂糖と小麦粉を使わないで
血糖値が上がりにくい材料で
お菓子を作れることを知りました
これなら罪悪感なく食べられる
そう思い ワクワクしながら
早速作って食べてみました
しかし
糖尿病の私が
仕方なく食べる「代用品」
その思いが拭えず
お腹は満たしても
心までは満たしてくれませんでした
ワクワクしながら
たくさん作った低糖質お菓子
それは
台所の隅にほったらかしにされ
結局 買ってきたお菓子を食べ過ぎて
後悔するという
以前と変わらない日々が続きました
遂には
食に携わる栄養士の仕事が
苦痛になったこともあり
仕事を辞めました
この先どうしようか 悩んでいたところ
飲食店に勤めている親の紹介で
店舗の空きスペースを借りて
夫婦二人で何かをすることになりました
しかし
何をしたらいいのか
何をしたいのかさえ 分かりませんでした
そんな私たちに
親が薦めてきたのは
低糖質のお菓子を出す
カフェでした
一応お店は開いたものの
まだ病気と向き合えていなかった私が
やる気も 自信も 無いままお菓子を作り
販売していたので
あまり多くの人に知られるのが嫌で
隠れるように
お店を開けていました
当然 お客さんもほとんど来なくて
来ても どう会話していいかさえ
わかりませんでした
そうして 半年ほどたった頃
あまりに嫌々作っている私を見かねた
夫の大介さんが
生まれて初めて お菓子を作り始めたんです
彼が作ってくれた低糖質のケーキを口にした時
美味しい と感じました
なぜ美味しかったのか
人に作ってもらったからなのか
実際に美味しかったのかは分かりません
でもとにかく 美味しかったんです
それから そのケーキが冷蔵庫にあると
嬉しくなりました
安心して美味しいケーキが食べられる
そのことで 私の頭の中を常に占めていた
食べたいという欲求が少しずつ減っていき
心に余裕が出始めました
そして気が付くと
病気になる前のように
「おやつの時間」が楽しみになっていたんです
私の気持ちが前向きになってきたこともあり
新しい土地で
本格的に低糖質お菓子のお店を
夫婦二人で始めることにしました
オープンして間もない頃
低糖質という うたい文句が珍しいことや
糖質制限がブームだったこともあり
取材の依頼が いくつか来ました
ありがたいことです
でも
私は世間に向けて
自分が糖尿病だと話すことに抵抗があり
取材を受けるのがとっても嫌でした
そんな私の心の内を知ってか知らずか
夫が勝手にどんどん話を進めてしまい
結局
いくつかの取材を受けることになりました
その後 新聞に掲載されたり
テレビで放映されたところ
思いがけず 多くの方がお店に来てくれました
なにより驚いたのは
食事制限で
甘いものを控えている人がたくさんいて
みんな ストレスを抱えていて
私たちの作るケーキを
美味しい
これなら安心して食べられる
そう言って
笑顔で食べてくれている
そんな光景が目の前に広がっていることでした
夫の作ってくれたケーキがきっかけで
失ったと思い込んでいた
「おやつの時間」を取り戻せたこと
そして
病気のことを
人に隠さずに伝えられたことで
私の中で糖尿病が少しずつ変化し
前向きに捉えて
生きていくことが
できるようになってきたのです
そして このことは
私だけでなく
お店に訪れるお客さんにも
変化をもたらすことになりました
ある日
テレビの放映を見たという
一人の女性が来店されました
女性は見るからに表情が暗く 話を聴くと
私と同じ１型糖尿病になったばかりで
悩みは尽きないようなのです
何度か来店されるうちに
私は あることが気になりはじめました
彼女が一度に
大量のケーキを買っていくということです
彼女は
「私たちのお店に出会って命が救われた」
と言ってくれるけれど
実のところ ケーキに依存し
病気という現実から目を背けるための
手段になっているのではないかと
感じました
ある時 彼女が
病気のことをずっと考えていると
気が滅入ってしまうから
一人旅をしてみたら少し気持ちがすっきりした
そう話してくれたのを聴いて
病気から逃げていた過去の自分と彼女が重なり
どうしたら彼女の悩みを解決できるのか
考えるようになりました
その後も 何度も来店し
会話を重ねるうちに
彼女に変化が現れてきました
お化粧をして
きれいな色の服を着てくるようになり
心配していた
ケーキを購入する数も 減っていきました
少しずつ笑顔も見られるようになってきたので
そのことを彼女へ伝えたところ
彼女が
「同じ病気でも 奥さんは笑顔で
輝いて見えるから ここでは笑えるの」
そう言ってくれたのを聴いて
私はハッとしました
私にできることは
彼女の悩みを解決することではなくて
カウンター越しでの何気ない会話を通じて
糖尿病でも人生は楽しめるんだと
感じてもらい
安心して 美味しいケーキを
食べてもらうことだけでいいのかもしれないと
気づかされたのです
美味しいコーヒーと
ケーキと共に会話を楽しむ時間
これって私が大好きな
「おやつの時間」に他ならなかったのです
このことに気づいた私はある行動に出ました
同じように１型糖尿病を突然発症し
不安や孤独を抱えているように見えた
別のお客さんの女性を
私達の「おやつの時間」に誘ってみたのです
喜んで来てくれて
たくさんおしゃべりをして
来た時よりも笑顔になって帰っていきました
その後 お二人一緒に
お店に来てくれるようになりました
ある時二人が
ここのお店では
病気について堂々とお話ができるし
共感しあえる安心感があると
言ってくれました
悩んでいるのは自分一人だけではないと気づき
同じ悩みを抱える人同士がつながり
気持ちが前向きになれる場所
そんなサロンのような役割を
私たちのお店は担うことができたのです
オープンして間もなく１年を迎えますが
お店に来てくれるお客さんの理由は様々です
食事制限をしている主人が
美味しいと喜んでくれた
そう言って 何度も来てくれる奥さん
糖尿病のおじいちゃんのために
みんなでお祝いできる
ケーキを買いに来たというお孫さん
カウンターに座り
私たちに気持ちを打ち明けてくれる人もいます
かつては
私が仕方なく食べていた低糖質ケーキが
私自身を変え
今では
人を喜ばせ
希望を与えるものにさえなったのです
私はこれからも もっと多くの人に
食事制限があっても
「おやつの時間」を楽しめる方法があるのだ
ということを伝えていきたいと思います
私は
糖尿病を発症した当初
糖尿病を
それに伴う食事制限を
とにかくネガティブなものと思い込み
苦しんでいました
自分が勝手に思い込んでいることって
意外と多いのだと思います
周りがそう言うからとか
常識だからとか
でも もしかしたら
自分にとっては
違う意味になりうるかもしれない
そのことに気づき
行動した時
自分が思ってもみなかったようなことが
身の周りで起こるかもしれません
そして
一人で悩みを抱え込んでいるのって
とってもつらいです
だからもし
自分と同じような境遇で悩んでいる人がいたら
あなたの「おやつの時間」に
誘ってみましょう
美味しい飲み物と
お菓子を楽しみながら
心の内を共有し
受け入れることができたら
共に前へ一歩
踏み出すことが できると思うんです
私が笑顔になったことで
お店に来てくれる人も一緒に
笑顔になってくれたように
（拍手）